NowThis: I can’t breathe. I can’t breathe.
New York Times: Hands up, don’t
shoot. Hands up, don’t shoot.
Ruptly: Di Su Nombre, George Floyd,
Di Su Nombre, George Floyd, Di Su
Nombre,George Floyd, Di Su Nombre.
TODAY: Overnight, Chaos in Minneapolis.
Sky News: The biggest gathering
that London has seen in weeks.
Face The Nation: From Berlin, to Seoul, South
Korea, to Rio in Brazil, to Sydney, Australia.
CBS: Everywhere, George Floyd’s
death has struck a mighty chord.
ODUAH: So they're always looking at America
with rose colored glasses or whatever. But now,
you know, I think that that view
of America as a beacon of hope and
democracy has been tinted and they are
somewhat disillusioned by this current
administration and they're making
comments to reflect their thoughts.
RICHBURG:
After the murder of George Floyd on television,
and it was a murder, I had people walking up to
me or I had students knocking on my door saying,
"Oh my God, what's happening in America? What's
going on? Can you explain it to us?" And, and I
really couldn't explain it. What, what do you say?
I mean, how do you explain something like that?
SIERRA: Why It Matters spends a lot of time
discussing how things that happen around the
world affect us at home. But today we
are going to flip that around. Because,
the killing of George Floyd, the protests
against police brutality and systemic racism,
and the administration’s response, are not
only unfolding here, in the United States.
The world is listening, too. And depending on
where you are, the echoes can sound different.
To better understand how this is playing out, we
turned to two American journalists who have spent
their careers reporting abroad. We asked them
to give us their own thoughts and experiences,
and to describe what America looks
like, right now, through the eyes of
those who are watching from afar. They told
us about two places; Africa, and Hong Kong.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters. Today, diplomacy starts at home.
RICHBURG: This kind of reminds me
how, throughout history, you know,
and I've studied history and political science,
throughout history, America's goal and mission,
of trying to go around to promote democracy and
human rights around the world has constantly
been undercut by how they treat minorities
and particularly African Americans at home.
I'm Keith Richburg, I'm currently
the Director of the Journalism and
Media Studies Center at The University of
Hong Kong, but I spent most of my career,
about 34 years as a reporter, and
correspondent for The Washington Post.
During the Cold War, the old Soviet Union
propagandists used to take great pleasure
in pointing out how Black Americans were treated
in the American South during the Jim Crow era.
You know, the propagandists during the Vietnam
War would like to point out how American Blacks
were being treated. You know, we were not able
to really, as strongly as we wanted to, stand up
against the Apartheid regime in South Africa in
its early days, because the Apartheid regime in
South Africa was in many ways modeled on the Jim
Crow segregation laws of the American South. So I
think throughout history, America's stated mission
and goal of promoting democracy and human rights,
and Roosevelt's four freedoms around the world
have constantly been undercut by enemies who were
willing to point out the hypocrisy of America's
positions and America's promotion of human rights,
by saying, "Before you come lecture us, why
don't you deal with your own problems at home?”.
ODUAH: It's quite painful for me because I do have
both experiences, you know, living in America,
born in Nigeria, I do have both views and
I've experienced this racism in America.
My name is Chika Oduah. I am an independent
multimedia journalist. I am based in West Africa,
and I cover the entire continent for
various international media outlets.
The killing of George Floyd was very
jarring. It was a wake up. It was a
brutal awakening for people who actually
don't quite believe racism is as real as
African Americans say that it is. You’ve still
got people who don't believe it's that strong,
who believe that it's from the past, that
there have been many, moves towards overcoming,
you know, some people still believe that America
is a post racial society. So for this incident,
this killing of George Floyd it’s like, "Oh,
actually, it's still there, you know, and we
saw it on TV. We saw this guy breathing for his
life for nearly nine minutes." So in that aspect,
it is a rude awakening. It's really provoking
some nations to look inward, you know, look at
their own injustice. For example, in France, you
know, people there were calling for an end to the
choke hold that some police officers use. And so
they're having debates on how to handle people.
RICHBURG: You know, I was overseas, when the
Rodney King episode happened in Los Angeles,
1992, and you started to see riots
going on. I was in Nairobi, Kenya,
and while the U.S. was criticizing the Kenyan
government for using the police to violently
break up pro-democracy demonstrations in Kenya,
they could easily point back to the U.S. and say,
"Well, why don't you deal with your own situation
before you come and lecture us." I have to say,
as a Black reporter overseas, I've constantly
heard it said to me by officials, whether
they'd be from China, or in the Middle East,
or elsewhere, saying, "Well, hold on. You're
Black. So you understand what I'm talking about.
You know how bad the U.S. is. You know how bad
the U.S. government is." As if I'm supposed to
kind of be able to take sides with, you know,
an oppressive government because I'm supposed to
know that the U.S. government is also oppressive.
SIERRA:
So, what's it like being an
American in Hong Kong right now?
RICHBURG: Well, it's, it's really interesting.
You've got a lot of things going on here at
the same time. We've been dealing with one
year since the massive protests started,
since the now pulled Extradition Bill, and it's
been a year of turmoil really. I mean, last year,
2019, almost every weekend was a different protest
or demonstration in the streets. Some of them,
incredibly violent with police on both
sides, police violence, protester violence,
vandalism. Uh, it kind of culminated in November
11th when the city just kind of exploded.
South China Morning Post: Hong Kong Protest.
RICHBURG: The universities were taken over by
students who were battling police, and now I'm
watching the U.S. and while Hong Kong is, uh,
relatively quiet, the U.S. seems to have this
protest movement that's kind of only growing,
and becoming more sustained, so it's kind of
interesting now to watch, you know, the U.S. going
through what we went through. And the other major
thing that's happened is the Chinese government
in Beijing has announced it's going to impose a
new national security law on Hong Kong. This is
the thing that President Trump said is really
kind of stripping away Hong Kong's autonomy. But
from the Chinese perspective, it gives the police,
and the Chinese government new tools to be able
to control, the unrest that we've been seeing. So,
I think that you, you can basically call
it a crackdown coming from the north.
SIERRA: So you brought up President Trump.
A lot of people are saying that the way the
Trump administration reacted to anti-racism
protests, following the killing of George
Floyd has undercut our moral authority
abroad. Do you feel like this is the case?
RICHBURG: I think it's definitely the case that
the, the Trump administration's reaction to the
protests, and the actual protests themselves have
totally undercut America's kind of moral standing,
and ability to chastise others abroad for
how they deal with demonstrators. You know,
here in Hong Kong, we saw very violent
police reaction to peaceful protests
that started in June 9th of 2019. Uh, the
police used tear gas, they've used rubber
bullets. They've used live bullets in a
few occasions. I've seen them beating,
you know, handcuffed, and perfectly subdued
protestors, who were not resisting arrest,
real incidents of police brutality. I've seen them
covering up their badges, and their identifying
numbers with black tape, so we, there's no way
you could actually report who was doing what.
SIERRA: Wow.
RICHBURG: All of this has been captured on
video, and the administration through the
state department, and through the U.S. consulate
here has consistently condemned these kind of,
violent action against peaceful protestors,
but now we see police in the U.S. doing the
same things, it's really kind of like
watching an echo going on now, so yeah,
it's really sapped I think the moral authority
of the U.S. and U.S. officials to kind of
criticize what's going on, you know, here
in Hong Kong, and elsewhere in the world.
For example, there was a really, biting cartoon
in China Daily, which is one of the communist
owned party English language newspapers showing
a policeman wearing a KU Klux Klan hood with
his knee on the neck of the Statue of Liberty.
And the, and the cartoon was labeled, you know,
“racism”. It's just the sort of thing that
is almost a godsend to the Beijing government
propagandists, to say, "You see, you see what
we're dealing with here? Look at the hypocrisy."
SIERRA: How is the African media
covering the killing of George Floyd?
ODUAH: I think the African community, both within
the United States and back on the continent,
there's a lot of intrigue about this particular
killing. And the media has also played a big role
in trying to educate people in Africa about
what is going on. There's a lot of questions.
There's some general assumptions that racism
is the order of the day, but you do have some
media trying to explain it. So in this case,
Africans like myself were called upon as foreign
correspondents to explain what's happening, the,
the turmoil that we see in the United States.
SIERRA: And what sort of reactions
are you seeing to the protests?
ODUAH: There's a lot of sympathy. You know,
we're seeing overwhelming solidarity for the
demand for justice, and I think that this
is a page turner. It's, it's not something
that we always see with Africans. Sometimes,
there's some blame, towards the African American
community for whatever reason, but now there
seems to be a lot of sympathy and solidarity.
SIERRA: What kinds of opinions were you
hearing about black Americans in Africa before?
ODUAH: That's a really good question. I mean, for
example, in Nigeria, there are diverse opinions
to racism in America. I've met some Nigerians
who just don't understand it. And the reason
why Nigerians typically don't quite understand
racism is because they've never experienced it
firsthand. Nigeria was not a settler colony. I
mean, you know, it was a British colony, sure,
but you didn't see large populations of British
people or Europeans living in Nigeria. So for the
most part, Nigerians have kind of run their state
of affairs. They've never had large numbers of
British people in their societies. So they don't
quite understand racism in the way that African
Americans have experienced it. I've come across
people who say African Americans are threatening,
that maybe they are criminals, that they're at
the wrong place at the wrong time. You know,
things like that. A lot of prejudices that really
speak to gaps in the black experience. I mean the
black experience is not one single experience.
And for a lot of people on the continent,
they don't quite share what African Americans
experience. If you go to Southern Africa, you
know, like South Africa, Zimbabwe, Zambia, these
countries did experience large populations of
Europeans in their communities. These were what we
call settler colonies. So they did experience, you
know, having white people govern them. So in those
places, they have a better understanding of racism
in America because they experienced apartheid,
which was legalized racism in their society.
Africans also have a stake in what's happening in
terms of racism and police brutality in America,
because Africans have also been affected. I mean,
some of us know the case of Amadou Diallo in New
York who was shot simply because he reached
into his pocket trying to get his wallet. And
that happened in 1999. There have been other
cases of Africans shot by police in America.
So we've gotta see this I'm saying, we,
because I'm African as well, we have to
see that we're also invested in American
society. Many of us come here for education,
we come here for economic opportunities, we come
here to get houses, things like that. We can be
targeted, you know. Oftentimes Africans
like to see themselves as different from
African Americans when they come here and
say, "Oh, we're different. We're not the
same. We have different histories." But
to a racist, we are the same, you know,
if you just look at us on the street, we're the
same. And I'd like for Africans to remember that.
SIERRA: Do you think that these
mass protests that we're having in
the U.S. have caused observers abroad
to draw stronger distinctions between
the values of American people and the
values of the current administration?
ODUAH: You know, many Africans are studying
the American political landscape. They like
to see what's going on. I've got relatives in
Nigeria who follow it so closely that you think
that they're living in America, but they're
not. They just follow it so closely because
they aspire to be like America. They
want their societies to be democratic,
to be emblems of unity and free thinking and
progressive politics. But now, you know, I
think that view of America as a beacon of hope and
democracy has been tinted and they are somewhat
disillusioned by this current administration and
they're making comments to reflect their thoughts.
SIERRA: What sentiments have you encountered
in your reporting about the upcoming election
in the U.S.? You know, what do you think changes
for Africa when the U.S. administration changes?
ODUAH: The views are so diverse. You know, I would
say in the likes of many West African countries,
some people do want to see Trump remain
because they believe that Trump will
help to fight against terrorism. You know, the
likes of Mali, Burkina Faso, Chad and Nigeria,
which are seeing, you know, heightened acts
of terrorism by several terrorist groups,
not just one. They want to see Trump because
they feel like he's doing a good job,
or he will try to make greater efforts and trying
to fight that and combat that with, you know,
U.S. soldiers on [the] ground. So in that aspect,
some people would like to see him remain. But then
others, you know, they don't think that he's
for Africa. They don't see him trying to bring
economic ties with Africa. America is really
losing out. We're seeing China, we're seeing
Russia coming in. We're seeing Germany coming
in trying to forge and strengthen economic ties,
but America not so much. Trump has been, you
know, quiet on that aspect. I don't think he
really sees Africa as an opportunity for him
economically or, or politically, I mean, at all.
RICHBURG: Before the protesters in Hong Kong were
calling on the U.S. government for help. One of
the things that I found most striking about the
last year of protest in Hong Kong were the number
of American flags I saw the protestors flying or
displaying in the middle of protest. They were
calling on the U.S. Congress to implement the Hong
Kong Democracy Act. They were calling on the U.S.
to take away Hong Kong’s special status. They were
marching in peaceful numbers to the U.S. Consulate
here in Hong Kong, and begging the U.S Consulate
to do something, to help promote democracy in
Hong Kong, and so now it's the Chinese government,
and the pro-Beijing side that's basically saying,
“Look, look at what the Americans are doing to
their own people. You think they're going to come,
and help you here in Hong Kong?” Of course,
racism and injustice persist. But I always
try to tell people, look, America is a
very big and a very complicated place,
and please do not lose sight of the fact that
we did elect a black man as president. In fact,
we elected him twice. So it wasn't a fluke.
We have now more black elected officials than
probably at any time in history. We have more
black CEOs, we have more black journalists,
we have more black millionaires, we have more
black judges. You still have problems of racial
injustice and racial inequality, but at the same
time, America is constantly making progress,
and it's a country that constantly takes in
my view, two steps forward, and one step back.
SIERRA: What do you think the
reaction has been from mainland
Chinese citizens? How are they seeing this moment?
RICHBURG: Well, it's a good question. You know,
and I, it's hard to actually speak for mainland
China because it's a huge country. It's 1.4
billion people, diverse. I think you're going
to see some drawback of Chinese, students, going
to the United States to study or Chinese wanting
to immigrate to the United States. Anytime there
is a story in the United States or Canada or
Australia of racism directed against Asians -
and we've seen many ugly incidents of racism.
Those stories are front page news in China.
Those stories are front page news in Hong Kong,
because there's a message the Chinese government
is trying to send out, which is, "You see how
bad it is there? You're going to be discriminated
against there. You're better off back here because
look how racist they are in America." Now, the
irony is that China can be just as racist and
Chinese can be just as racist as we saw when they
were discriminating against blacks and Africans in
Guangzhou, basically accusing blacks and Africans
in Guangzhou and Southern China of bringing the
coronavirus. There were literally signs
in McDonalds saying, "We don't serve black
people." So China can be just as racist, but they
love picking up these stories because it feeds
their larger narrative that the west is not some
panacea, that Chinese should stay home in China.
SIERRA: So switching gears a
little bit to your own experience,
what insights do you have about the treatment
of the press in the U.S. during these protests,
and, you know, over the last few
years by this administration?
ODUAH: You know, it really reminds me of what
happens in Africa. Seeing the president of the
United States call the National Guard,
tear gassing journalists, tear gassing,
peaceful protesters, you know, it just
makes me think of authoritarian regimes
in Africa. The likes of Rwanda, where media
has been suppressed, the likes of Nigeria,
many countries we're seeing this. Ethiopia,
Eritrea, journalists are not wanted, and those
administrations will do anything that they can
to stop the media from telling the story. So,
for me, this is just like, a lot of people
like to describe Trump as an African president.
RICHBURG: I can't count how many statements
the Foreign Correspondents Club, or the FCC,
has put out condemning the use of tear gas
against journalists, the use of pepper spray,
journalists shot by rubber bullets. Here in Hong
Kong, this Indonesian female journalist was shot
in the eye with a rubber bullet, and was blinded.
The police still have not resolved that case. And
then I was just kind of almost stunned to see that
there was an American photographer who was shot
in the eye with a rubber bullet, and similarly
blinded in one eye, and it's almost like I'm
watching what happened here in Hong Kong unfold
in slow motion again in The United States. I've
seen journalists pepper sprayed, I was watching
a journalist, a female reporter in Louisville,
Kentucky, I believe it was, who was hit by rubber
bullets while she was on the air live. I've seen
journalists hit with batons. It's happened to
journalists from all over the world. It’s really
been disheartening because we first saw this echo
from The United States and from the White House,
coming here, when President Trump started
using this phrase “fake news”. Everything in
the U.S. is fake news, and that was picked up by
dictators and autocrats in this part of the world,
from Hun Sen in Cambodia, to the military regime
in Myanmar, which tried to cover up their massacre
of the Rohingya Muslims by calling it all fake
news the Chinese government calls anything it
doesn't like fake news, the Thai military will
call anything fake news. So we've seen now this
echo of Trump coming out here in this direction.
And then you see this kind of brutal activity of
the police now, and I fear that that's going to
become a second case, where people will think now,
in this part of the world, that they can get
away with this kind of treatment of journalists,
firing rubber bullets at them, using
tear gas, because they're gonna say,
"Hold on a second. If you're doing it in the
U.S., how can you criticize us for doing it?"
SIERRA: It's the kind of trend setting
you don't wanna be, you know, setting,
making the jobs of authoritarian
leaders easier around the world.
RICHBURG: Yeah. It's not the trend we wanna
be setting. I believe Richard Haass, you know,
the President of the Council on Foreign Relations,
I believe he always talks about how foreign policy
begins at home, and I really do believe that's
true. You know, our greatest asset in our foreign
policy is our own behavior at home. And if we
could set an example that here's how we deal
with peaceful demonstrations in the U.S.,
here's how we respect journalistic freedom,
here's how we respect freedom of the press, here's
how we treat our minorities, here's how we treat
the Black population that's facing injustice.
If we could show, by the power of our example,
how we do things I think we can regain that moral
authority. I was a foreign correspondent in 2009
after Obama was elected. And it was amazing how
transformative the election of Barack Obama was.
I was overseas. I was based in Europe. I was
a Paris correspondent for the Washington Post
when the United States invaded Iraq. And I
thought this would take forever to repair
America's image after the disastrous war in Iraq.
But then the moment you had the election in 2008,
when Obama was elected, and I came back into
Asia. And I would walk through airports,
whether it was Beijing or Jakarta or Bangkok, and
I kid you not, uh, immigration officers at the
airports would look at my passport, see an, a see
an American, they'd look up and see a black man,
and they would, they would give me the thumbs up
and have big smile, because what we do in the U.S.
does make a difference around the world. It does
permeate around the world. And I hope it can be
seen. I mean, I'm not going to predict anything.
We all were looking at the polls, but I hope
this era we're in now is eventually seen as an
aberration and not who the Americans really are.
ODUAH: I think that this is a great
opportunity for Africans on the continent,
both in terms of citizens and government,
to really stand in solidarity with African
Americans. I think that this is a great chance
to bridge that long standing gap. There have
been some attempts to connect, you know, too
black people across the pond, but largely,
those efforts have been weak. You know, we did
see the likes of Malcolm X, for example, and
Maya Angelou, and Martin Luther King. These black
figures did go to Africa and they were inspired.
You’ve also got cases of African heroes who
did go to United States, seeking inspiration
and went back to their countries to fuel
movements, independence movements. I’d
like to see more of that. I’d like to see more
comradery, more collaboration, more dialogue
between African Americans and Africa. So I think
this is a great opportunity to see that happen.
ODUAH: I mean, growing up here, I remember being
targeted for my skin color, being targeted for
being Nigerian, for being African. So I kind of
have a holistic grasp on the entire, uh, on all
of these racist agendas and sentiments. So for me,
it's quite heartbreaking. There are times where
I've had to explain and justify my right to exist
in America. And I lived in the South, you know,
Atlanta, Georgia, and you see a lot of deep
racism in the South. It's still there. Some of my
classmates were racist. Some of my neighbors were
racist. And once they find out that we're not just
black, but we're African they're even angrier, you
know, some people. So for me, it's very personal.
So I do find myself crying when I hear stories
like George Floyd and Amadou Diallo and Breonna
Taylor and Ahmaud Arbery. It really disturbs my
soul to be honest. And so for me, I definitely
identify with the black experience, the diversity
of black experiences, and that experience does
come with persecution, with being targeted.
So I like to speak as a voice for both African
Americans and Africans. And like I said earlier, I
would love to see more solidarity between African
Americans and Africans, because these groups
have historically misunderstood each other.
RICHBURG: One of my earliest and most vivid
childhood memories was being nine years old
when the city of Detroit experienced, what was
then one of the worst riots in American history.
It was a riot that had its roots in a lot of
economic and social issues, but primarily in
the brutality of a primarily white police force in
the city of Detroit. And it ended up with about 43
people dead, I think, by the count of the Detroit
Free Press and the other papers. Most of them were
people who were shot by police or national
guardsmen. I remember my father taking me as
a nine year old kid, you know, me and my brother
to go watch the burning down of the shop, little
strip mall where we used to go buy our comic books
and buy our candy at the Kresge's. And you know,
why would you take little kids there? He said,
"I want you to see this. I want you to see
what these people are doing to their own city.
There's no point in rioting." The 1967 riots,
it perpetuated a lot of change. It eventually
led to the election in 1973 of Coleman Young,
the first black mayor of Detroit. It led to the
integration of the police in Detroit. You know,
out of bad things can come something good and
out of the Detroit riots, you did get this kind
of reform. I would like to think that out of
these protests over the death of George Floyd,
we might get something good. We maybe will
get real police reform, that people have
been talking about for a while. So I, that's what
I'm really hopeful for. So maybe everything that
I saw in 1967 is kind of coming to a head now
and it just, you know, it just took 53 years.
That's all. I mean, we get ... we eventually get
there. It takes us a while, but we do get there.
9 News Australia:
This is not something that only happens in the
U.S., it’s something that is happening globally.
Bloomberg: Everyone keeps saying “Oh, Australia
is so different”, but it’s not really.
France 24: We need to take a deep
look into ourselves as French people.
Al Jazeera: People think the UK is innocent, the
UK is not innocent. It happens here everyday.
France 24: We are sick and tired of the police
brutality. We want justice for everyone,
regardless of in Kenya or all over
the world. Nobody needs to be killed,
nobody needs to be beaten.
France 24: Black lives matter. And it doesn’t mean
that other lives do not matter. There is only one
house burning, and we’ll all pay attention
to that house. It doesn’t mean other houses
are not important, they too are important.
But this house is the one that is burning.
SIERRA: There’s a lot more to learn about
how this moment is affecting the world,
so please visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters where
you can find show notes and resources.
Interested in saying hi to the Why It Matters
team? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Be sure to subscribe to the show on Apple
Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you
get your audio. And if you like the show, leave
us a review! Why It Matters is a production of
the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Jeremy Sherlick,
Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria and our summer intern
is Wynne Dieffenbach. Robert McMahon is our
Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief
Digital Officer. Original music is composed by
Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks go to Richard
Haass, Jeff Reinke and the Carolina Chocolate
Drops for allowing us to use their beautiful
music in the outro. For Why It Matters this is
Gabrielle Sierra signing off. See you in a bit.